foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the dragon video in this video
I want to show you what happens to
renira's son who carries valerion as
well as his dragon arax as you all know
in the most recent episode of House of
the Dragon we saw aemon Targaryen fight
renira's son shortly after he mounted
Veigar during this fight aemon loses his
eye after lucari slashes him in the face
with a dagger afterwards we hear Amon
say one of the greatest lines from the
season thus far he says do not Mourn Me
Mother it was a fair exchange I may have
lost an eye but I gained a dragon I
literally threw my fist into the air in
excitement as I heard him say that line
now it may have sounded like aemon was
not very upset about losing his eye
however if you watch my video you will
see exactly how he will eventually get
his revenge and I must say it's one of
the most Savage events during the dance
of the Dragons how aemon gets his
revenge immediately lets us know the
games are over this is how the war of
fire and and blood officially begins now
unlike what's happening in Westeros
right now let me tell you about a game
that's actually fun I want to thank the
sponsor of today's video and my favorite
game raid Shadow Legends now for those
of you who don't know raid is the
coolest and most addictive game out
there it features a massive Universe
where you get to build up your team of
Champions with over 600 to choose from
to fight in player vs player matches or
boss battles although the game
celebrated its three-year anniversary
this year it isn't too late for you to
jump right in and start playing all of
you can use my QR code or the links
below to download raid yourself to your
mobile phone or even your PC raids
started strong from the very beginning
and never slowed down last year raid
added a whole new faction the shadow kin
are a tribe of Warriors from the Far
East recently liberated from the reign
of evil for me they are one of the
coolest factions in the game another
amazing addition to the game is the
Hydra Clan boss it's without a doubt the
biggest baddest and scariest boss to
ever set foot in the Talaria this month
rage just released a giant new feature
Awakening and a brutal new dungeon the
iron twins Fortress now if you're good
enough to take down the iron twins
you'll see a huge payoff being able to
awaken your Champions now wait here's
the big news raid has just released a
super powered legendary version of
everybody's favorite Champion death
knight the whole raid Community has been
waiting for this for a long time and
Ultimate Death Knight is everything we
hope for he's poised he's powerful he's
perfect and the best part is everyone
can get him for free all you have to do
is log in and play raid for seven days
from now until October 27th and you'll
get Ultimate Death Knight it's easy you
can also use the DK Rises promo code for
a bunch of free items to instantly level
your new strongest Champion all the way
to level 50 and 5 Star Ascension and
there's even more new players use my
link or scan the QR code right here and
get a free starter pack worth almost 30
dollars a free champion Terrell and this
cool end game loot you will find all of
your rewards right here in the inbox for
the next 30 days only now once you
you're in you can find me in game under
the name talking Thrones and if you're
fast you can join my clan all you have
to do is click the link in the
description and I'll see you in the game
thanks again to rage Shadow Legends for
sponsoring this video
alright now let me show you how lucari's
valerion and his small Dragon receive a
devastating and fatal Blow from aemon in
his incredibly massive she Dragon vegar
this is something you will want to see
all the way until the very end after the
death of reniro's father viserys is when
things will get very interesting now for
those of you who don't know renera was
living on Dragonstone when she learns
that her father had died in Alison's son
aegon had ascended the iron throne and
now that we've seen runera in Allison's
relationship disintegrate right before
our very own eyes we all know renera
will have to fight if she wants to get
back or what is rightfully hers now
renera did have a slight advantage in
the air because she had more dragons and
she also had a major advantage at Sea
because she had House of valerion's
Fleet standing behind her however the
Army she would have on land left
something to be desired unfortunately
for rhaenyra Dragonstone was lightly
garrisoned there were only 30 nights a
hundred crossbowmen and 300 men at Arms
that made up dragonstone's Garrison that
that would be nowhere near enough men to
go up against house Hightower let alone
all of their allies as well if Rainer
were ever going to get back the Iron
Throne from aegon she knew she would
need a significant amount of help the
only issue was renera did not know who
else would stand beside her now at the
beginning of House of the Dragon we saw
all the Lords of Westeros swear fealty
to renera but that was when her father
was alive and before he had a male Heir
now Damon knew they would have to fight
this war with words before they would go
to battle the Lords of the great houses
of Westeros held the key to Victory
Damon insisted their bannermen and
vassals would follow where they LED
Allison and aegon may have had the
largest and richest cities in the realm
under their command but the rest of the
realm's great Lords had yet to declare
they were still up for grabs in rainey's
Targaryen was sure that Storm's end
would stand with them after all rhaenys
was of that blood on her mother's side
and the late Lord Borman had always been
the staunchest of friends Rainier was
hoping she would get house Baratheon and
its man on her side this is when Rainier
is Zelda's son Jace says that he should
be the one who delivers the message he
said dragons will win the Lords over
faster than Ravens his little brother
lucarius valerion agreed insisting that
he and Jace were men or near enough to
make no matter he also said our uncle
says we're strongs but when the Lord see
us on Dragon back they will know that
for a lie only targaryens ride dragons
now this is when rhaenyra said if you go
you go as Messengers only not as Knights
you will not engage in any other
fighting it was then decided that Jace
being the eldest would go on the longer
and more dangerous route flying first to
the Erie to greet with the lady of the
veil then to White Harbor to whenever
Lord manderly and lastly the Winterfell
to win over lord Stark her younger son
Luke's Mission would be the shorter and
safer route or so they thought he would
be flying to Storm's end where it was
expected that Boris Baratheon would give
him a warm welcome unfortunately the
tragedy that Bethel lucarius valerion
was a devastating event that sent shock
waves throughout Westeros when Lou
carries valerion arrived at Storm's end
in hopes of securing a great Ally for
his mother he soon realized Amon 1i
Targaryen was already there before him
now Boris Baratheon who we've met in
House of the Dragon already was a much
different man than his father acceptance
said Lord Baratheon was the wind that
rages and howls and blows this way in
that way amond one eye had been
uncertain what sort of welcome he would
receive when he set out from King's
Landing but Storm's end welcomed him by
having a feast and hunts and jousting as
well it seemed Lord Baratheon was
willing to entertain amond when he
arrived after all he did have four
daughters who all needed a husband and
he was hoping that aemon would choose
one for his wife you see this is when
Lord Baratheon tells aemon how renera
had taken house Baratheon for granted
for far too long Lord Baratheon wanted a
royal marriage in the offing something
he was not getting from rhaenyra or her
sons you're about to see how this has a
major effect on how lucarius will be
greeted once he enters Lord baratheon's
Great Hall now we have no record of
which daughter aim in one eye finally
decided on it's said that aemon and Lord
Baratheon were haggling over dates and
dowries on the morning Lucario's
valerion arrived vegar actually sensed
his arrival first Guardsmen who were
walking the battlements of the Castle's
mighty walls held their weapons firmly
in sudden fear when she woke with a
scream that shook the very foundations
of Storm's end the incredible sound
vagar made even scared Lucario's
valerion's dragon arax now mushroom and
avas believe that the lightning was
flashing to the East and a heavy rain
was falling as lucarius leapt off his
dragon with his mother's message still
held firmly in his hand he must have
surely known what it meant when he saw
the massive Sea Dragon Veigar was
already there before him so it shouldn't
have come as a surprise when Amon one
eye confronted him in the round Hall
before the Ides of Lord Baratheon his
four daughters the septon the maester as
well as as many guards and servants as
you can see there were a number of
witnesses who saw what happened next
look at this sad creature my Lord aemon
had yelled out little Luke strong the
bastard amond immediately starts with
the disrespect he wants a reaction out
of lucari's he wants a fight he wants
revenge for what happened to his eye Lou
carries valerion addressed himself only
to Lord Baratheon he said Lord boros
I've brought you a message from my
mother the queen aemon then said what
you really mean is the [ __ ] of
Dragonstone then he grabbed the letter
from lucari's hand but Lord Baratheon
commanded his Knights to intervene one
of them brought him raniera's letter to
the Deus where his lordship set upon the
throne of the storm Kings of old now no
man can honestly say what Lord Baratheon
was thinking at that moment the accounts
of those who were there differ markedly
from one or the other some say Lord
Baratheon was red-faced ain't abashed
While others say it seemed like he was
relishing in the moment mushroom says he
was drunk while the septins says he was
fearful of what might happen next
however everyone does agree on one thing
everyone knows what Laura Baratheon said
and did after this after the maester
whispered Rainier's message in his ear a
frown stole across Lord baratheon's face
he Scout at lucari's valerion and said
and if I do as your mother bids which
one of my daughters will you marry he
then gestured at the four daughters Lou
carries valerion could only blush my
Lord I'm not free to marry he said I'm
already set to Wed my cousin Reina
Targaryen I thought as much Lord
Baratheon said go home and tell your
[ __ ] mother that the Lord of storms in
is not a dog that she can whistle up and
need to set against her foes Lou carries
valerion immediately turned around and
left a round Hall after hearing this
that's when aemon one eye drew his sword
and said hold on strong first you must
give me what you owe he then removed the
cover over his eye and flung it to the
floor revealing the sapphire that set in
his eye socket underneath you have a
knife just as you did then let me remove
your eye then you can leave I only need
one Lou carries remembered what he had
sworn to his mother I will not fight you
he said I'm here as an Envoy only not as
a knight you came here as a craven in a
traitor aemon declared I will have your
eye or your life back outside the storm
was Raging Thunder rolled across the
castle the rain fell on blinding sheets
and there was great bolts of blue white
lightning filling the sky lighting
everything as bright as day now it was
bad weather for flying even for a dragon
and Iraq's could barely stay aloft when
aemon and vegar began hunting him like a
shark in the water had there been no
storm Luke Aries might have been able to
outfly vegar because Iraq's was a lot
younger and swifter but unfortunately
that day was as black as eamon's heart
says mushroom and so the dragons met
above shipbreaker Bay Watchers on the
castle wall saw a distant blast of flame
and heard a loud shriek cut right
through the Thunder then the dragons
were locked together lightning crackling
all around them vegar was five times the
size of her foe the hardened Survivor of
a hundred battles if the dragons did
fight it would not have lasted for very
long Iraq's fell from the sky broken to
be swallowed By the stormlash Waters of
the bay his head and neck washed up
Beneath The Cliffs of Storm's end three
days later to make a feast for the crabs
and seagulls mushroom says Lou carries
valerion's lifeless body washed up as
well and aemon cut out his eyes and gave
him to Lord baratheon's daughter as a
gift but that seems excessive now some
say vegar snatchly carries off the
dragon's back and swallowed him whole
there's even some who say lucari
survived the fall swam to safety but
lost all memory of who he was thereafter
spending the rest of his days as a
simple-minded fisherman most believe
Lucario's valerion died with his Dragon
he was 13 years of age his body was
never found and with his death the war
of envoys and Ravens and marriage
alliances came to an end in the war of
Fire and Blood officially began
aemond one eye Targaryen who would
henceforth be known as aemon the
kinslayer to his foes arrived back in
King's Landing having won the alliance
of stormzen for his brother aegon now if
he thought he was about to receive a
hero's welcome he was dead wrong
Allison's flesh went White when she
heard what he had done she was also
heard crying in saying mother have mercy
on us all Serato was not happy about
this either he's hard to have said you
only lost one eye but how could you be
so blind aegon however did not share
their concerns he did Welcome his
brother home with a feast and he held
him as the True Blood Of The Dragon and
announced that he had made a good
beginning on Dragonstone rhaenyra
collapsed when she was told of her son
Luke's death when the Black Council met
on Dragonstone to discuss how they would
strike back a raven arrived from
harrenhal Damon Targaryen wrote an eye
for an eye a sun for a son
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign